This next story is sort of the perfect epitome
of everything that is Donald Trump.
According to the former Department of Homeland
Security chief of staff, Miles Taylor, Donald
Trump floated the idea of swapping Puerto
Rico for Greenland in order to get rid of
some of those poor Puerto Ricans from dirty
Puerto Rico.
Yeah, this Kombai is like three or four different
stories.
So first, of course, is Trump's obvious disregard
for Puerto Rico.
We saw this during hurricane response in the
past.
You might remember Donald Trump showing up
in Puerto Rico and shooting rolls of paper
towels like basketballs.
Then there's the idea of the asshole country,
which mostly are countries with brown people.
And then there's the idea of Trump being interested
in acquiring Greenland, which is something
that came up.
I don't know if it was six months ago or twelve
months ago.
Just time feels so strange at this point.
And lastly, kind of tying it all together
is Donald Trump's completely deranged worldview,
his delusions of grandeur, his narcissism,
his complete lack of empathy.
So let's first go to the tape.
Here is Myles Taylor, former Department of
Homeland Security chief of staff, telling
the story himself on MSNBC, tear gas at the
border, etc..
I wonder what is the most in the conversations
are involved in.
Disturbing idea or thought or discussion that
you heard from President Trump?
That is sort of resonating and sitting with
you and still today.
We could probably go on for days about that,
although I'm going to tell you one thing that
just popped into my head, Howie.
There was a time when, of course, we were
spending a lot of our days down in Puerto
Rico after the hurricanes wreaked devastation
down there, U.S. Virgin Islands and other
places where there was a trip that we made
down there in August of 2018.
And I remember before we went, the president
said something.
And your viewers are going to be somewhat
familiar with this.
The president's talked before about wanting
to purchase Greenland.
But one time before we went down, he told
us not only did he want to purchase Greenland,
he actually said he wanted to see if we could
sell Puerto Rico.
Could we swap where do Rico for Greenland?
Because in his words, Puerto Rico was dirty
and the people were poor.
These are Americans, Halli, and we don't talk
about our fellow Americans that way.
So this is really pretty wild and completely
unconscionable and really something to contend
with.
It has to be an anecdote for some kind of
Hall of fame, although I don't know what we
would be commemorating in this Hall of Fame,
it wouldn't be anything good.
But it seems like that anecdote is historic
in some sense.
And I'm reminded of what Michelle Obama told
us during her DNC speech on the first night
of the Democratic National Convention Monday,
which was, if you think things couldn't possibly
get any worse, they can and they will if we
don't make a change this election now merely
as a thought experiment.
If Puerto Rico got to become part of Denmark,
the way Greenland is part of Denmark now,
Puerto Ricans might actually be better off
because my guess is Denmark wouldn't do to
Puerto Rico or neglect Puerto Rico in the
way that Donald Trump has neglected Puerto
Rico.
So from the standpoint of the Puerto Rican
people, it may be interesting to them to actually
become part of Denmark.
But of course, this is completely crazy in
every sense.
And it's very funny to hear the right continue
to insist that Latino voters are just that
they're on the verge.
They're so close of becoming Republicans and
abandoning the Democratic Party.
Then you hear this, and it's very hard to
fathom that that's the case.
And of course, Cubans are the most conservative
Latino group in the United States other than
Cubans.
There is very little Republicanism among Latino
Vought voters, Puerto Ricans, Dominicans,
Mexicans, Argentineans, so on and so forth.
And then, by the way, everybody who talked
about we need a business person running the
country like a business.
This is what you get.
This is what you get when you have someone
who says, if a piece of my business isn't
interesting, if a piece piece of my business
is a loss leader, if it's not profitable or
whatever.
Let me see if I can find some sucker to offload
it to or sell it to.
And that's how you get a president who says
maybe I could trade Puerto Rico for Greenland.
We.
I used the term earlier.
We are reaping what we've sown.
And that is exactly what you
see
in
this story.